حتى الان لازمنا نتابع طائرات الاستطلاع
الاسرائيليه وهي تحلق في سماء الحدود
الاسرائيليه المصريه عند معبر نتسانه تقوم
بعمليه تمشيط كامله
للمنطقه معارف الاسرائيليه ذكرت بان
المؤشرات تفيد بان اطلاق النار على الحدود
مع مصر لا علاقه له بالتهريب هيئه البث
الاسرائيليه اضافت بان الجيش الاسرائيلي
دفع بتعزيزات كبيره لمعبر نتسانا على
الحدود مع مصر كما نشاهد في الخبر العاجل
اسفل الشاشه الجيش الاسرائيلي اعلن اذن عن
مقتل جندي اسرائيلي ثالث في هذه العمليه
وفي هذا الحادث الامني على الحدود مع مصر
كذلك ايضا اعلن التحديد مطلق النار بعد
الاشتباكات بين الجيش ومسلحين الجيش
الاسرائيلي
لازال يحقق كما يقول في ملابسات هذا
الحادث يقوم بعمليات تمشيط واسعه للمنطقه
كمان نشاهد امامنا